a Democrat Senator has left the Democrat
Party and it's not Joe manchin a lot of
people thought it might be Joe manchin
because he's often the more moderate
vote who stymies Chuck schumers and Joe
Biden's plans but it wasn't him it was
Kirsten Cinema it was the other kind of
moderate vote who sometimes Democrats
plans she left she hasn't become a
republican she's become an independent
this is great news and it definitely
weakens the Democrat majority but it's
clearly more calculated than some people
are making it out to be because Kirsten
Cinema waited to make this announcement
until just after the Democrats know they
they won the Georgia senate seat so
almost immediately after Raphael Warnock
beats Herschel Walker in Georgia and the
Democrats know they've got a little bit
of a buffer in the Senate that's when
Kirsten Cinema leaves the party had she
announced that she was going to leave
the party back when her leaving the
party looked like it could throw control
of the Senate potentially to Republicans
that would have been huge so it's not
that significant but it's still somewhat
significant okay